il faut retenir le prénom de ses
interlocuteurs
le plus possible de retenir le nom des
gens oui d'accord oui vous connaissez un
petit peu le nom des gens ici un petit
peu ouais
[Rires]
non mais tu connais tu retiens vite les
prénoms toi moi j'ai un traitant du tout
ah mais je te jure parfois j'ai des amis
à la maison je recolle des trucs
je te jure quoi
se souvient pas de votre prénom
de ouf ou Cyril franchement la personne
que je connais qui a la plus grosse
mémoire des chansons numéro de téléphone
ça ça vous a servi donc
il se rappelle où il a vu les gens tu te
rappelles toujours où tu as vu les gens
ça se rappelle pas des prénoms ah si
c'est vrai on s'est vu dans les
premières interactions dans les
premières interactions des fois le
prénom peut nous échapper c'est plus
grave quand c'est dans les dernières
interactions
[Rires]
alors il faut être attentif à sa posture
pour se faire des amis oui alors ça
c'est le langage du corps en fait c'est
un truc assez connu c'est ce qu'on
appelle la loi des 7 %. alors 7 % comme
ça
veut dire qu'en fait dans un message
quand par exemple je suis en train de
vous parler
il y a que 7% qui concerne ce qui est
dit dans le message le reste c'est mes
mains
la façon dont 93% qui reste
ma manière de parler comment si je parle
au bas mon corps si je suis comme ça
donc oui le regard bien sûr donc 7 %
uniquement le contenu du message
donc il faut prendre en compte le reste
tout particulièrement si on a envie de
créer un lien amical avec des gens mais
je crois que c'est valable pour tout ça
d'une manière générale voilà c'est sûr
c'est sûr
c'est la posture du corps à ne pas avoir
du coup on dit que par exemple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'il y a des postures à ne pas
voir croiser les bras non on dit en
général
[Rires]
les bras alors oui en fait c'est vrai
que les gens qui croisent les doigts la
dernière fois mercredi soir la soirée
Daniel j'ai croisé
non mais si vous dites à quelqu'un Cyril
vous êtes super sympa puis que vous êtes
comme ça le message passe moins 7%
passent mais pas les 93
[Applaudissements]
vous avez compris ce message
j'ai grand fauve fermer les boutons
[Musique]
déjà vous savez l'un contre l'autre sur
une moto je peux
[Applaudissements]
je suis totalement désolé mais je
m'exerce en couple
bouge plus quoi
[Rires]
ça peut non
[Applaudissements]
ça bouge plus ça bouge plus alors
troisième conseil pour se faire des amis
ne pas jouer un rôle essayer d'être le
plus sincère possible alors là je crois
que c'est le conseil le plus important
ce qu'on appelle l'acceptation
s'accepter tel qu'on est avec ses
qualités ses défauts bon voilà
s'accepter c'est accepter l'autre oui
accepter l'autre exactement et surtout
ne pas tricher ne pas jouer un rôle non
mais c'est c'est bien et par exemple
c'est vrai qu'un timide qui va jouer un
rôle on va voir qu'il est timide et il
va passer pour quelqu'un d'arrogant
parce que il va il va mettre un masque
de d'arrogance
oui moi j'ai une question comment se
faire ami avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas
envie et qui s'en bat les de nous
avec des gens qui qui n'ont pas envie je
crois que j'ai pas de solution parce que
la personne qui a pas envie d'être avis
avec vous je vois pas tellement
l'intérêt d'essayer d'insister à moins
que vous avez un point particulier enfin
vous pensez à quelque chose de
particulier ou oui à Cannes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu me dégoûtes et je suis pas le seul il
a pas eu quand même Guillaume parce que
il y a aussi les sexfriends ah ouais ça
existe
et donc ouais
ok ok
à l'amitié entre un homme et une femme
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec une ancienne amoureuse
[Rires]
ça facilite pas l'amitié quand tu dois
quand tu dois de l'oseille à la meuf
normalement vous vous restez amis avec
vos actes
sont partenaires et des amis du sexe
opposé ou pas ah oui
importants
[Applaudissements]
mais si c'est son meilleur ami mais
avant de vous
il s'appelle Christopher salut
Christopher et
pas la vérité on est comme des frères et
soeurs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous aurez une nouvelle une
fiancée
si elle a un copain qui sont meilleurs
amis et qu'elle connaît d'avant vous
vous voudrez plus quelle qu'elle puisse
être avec dîner avec etc
faut que je valide il faut que je valide
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais par exemple vous appelez votre
compagne ça va chéri tout ça j'entends
le gars entendu bruit et vous dites
tiens tu es pas tu es au resto tu es
sorti oui je suis avec des amis c'est
qui tu ne les connais pas
donc il y a pas besoin de donner le nom
et tout ça et donc elle raccroche après
c'est grave ou alors elle avait un
téléphone avec Darty
des années 80
mais elle fait les numéros quand même
c'est quoi ton histoire là parce que
donc tu attends et donc ce qu'il est en
train de dire je te le résumé
avec qui elle a dit tu ne les connais
pas raccrocher et de lui c'est une
histoire vraie donc ça date de de
une solution
pour ceux qui nous regardent si toi
aussi tu penses être cocu
au 88500
oui parce que là on rentre un peu dans
les rapports
matrimoniaux enfin de la musique etc on
sort un peu de ah oui d'accord c'est pas
votre vie
je veux bien en parler également mais là
on est plus dans les jalousie on peut
faire une petite vierge un peu d'accord
vide comme ça c'est difficile de vous
conseiller il faudrait que on en ait
parlait un peu plus c'est vrai que non
mais une phrase comme ça ça va
compagne
vous l'avez au téléphone et elle vous
dit
quel type de réaction je pourrais avoir
moi j'ai rien dire
parce que tu as entendu en fond
de te dire ensemble
ce que tu as entendu non mais qu'est-ce
que tu as entendu
de la rejoindre elle m'a demandé alors
là c'est le point positif elle m'a
demandé après mais quand elle est
rentrée
[Rires]
oui à quel restaurant
je pense qu'elle savait que je viendrai
pas mais en fait je raconte ça mais il y
a
la question c'est ce qu'on est obligé
tout à fait normal
il y a une solution très simple c'est le
FaceTime de contrôle bien sûr mec ne
répond pas au freestyle de contrôle
c'est des conseils que
je donne ce que je peux aussi donner des
conseils si vous commencez à dire tu es
là alors fais une vidéo
sur quelque part il y a des talons à
côté on a
n'a pas besoin on arrête on sait plus
rien mais je te jure mais si elle répond
pas au resto dans le noir c'est tout oui
je te sens nerveux quand même
alors excuse-moi je vais défendre
Guillaume là-dessus pour moi le FaceTime
de contrôle
si tu lui
disant
tu brise la confiance ça pue la peine
d'aller avancer plus dans le même chemin
toi tu vas faire un petit facteur de
contrôle quand ta meuf sera au Perche
il y a pas de problème frère je suis sûr
de contrôle il a raison en retard
exactement
oui comme tu as pas de réseau va sur
WhatsApp non c'est insupportable
on a touché quelque chose
à toucher le gâteau
depuis tout le temps j'en ferai jamais
dire que j'en ferai jamais à aucun
FaceTime aucun appel
je te jure aucun non mais les mecs aucun
arrêtez je le dis au téléspectateurs moi
si la personne n'accepte pas le FaceTime
et je dis pas ça pour toi Raymond parce
que toi c'est ça c'est un
principe il faut quand même se poser des
questions maintenant parce qu'en fait
c'est gênant
parce que des fois tu es pas prêté tu
vois ce que je veux dire
on est les plus claires
même avec ma propre famille bah ouais
c'est ça il répond pas à ta mère
[Rires]
m'appelle
gênant quand même le prolongement de la
question de Gilles est-ce que quand on a
un couple on doit avoir les mêmes amis
comment se fait-il que Fatou par exemple
et enfin sans doute Fatou et des amis et
que lui ne connaissent pas ses amis
est-ce que c'est possible
sur ça j'ai la réponse prends un autre
exemple on doit être ça doit être
conciliable quand même les amis les uns
des autres ça dépend vraiment du
contexte de la confiance qu'il y a dans
le couple du nombre d'années qu'on a je
sais pas quel est avec votre femme si ça
fait des années 80
mais ils sont mariés non mais il y a pas
une demande en mariage
[Applaudissements]
dans quel contexte des choses se passent
et les degrés de confiance après c'est
vrai que le FaceTime tout ça moi
personnellement je le sens pas trop mais
non mais
un avis personnel
dans certains cas peut-être que ça peut
changer de contrôle bien sûr et je le
dis ce soir et ça montre c'est la
transparence
t'as pas aux toilettes à 2h du matin
avec la musique
de charbon pour éviter les festins de
confort je tiens en allant arrête
ils sont investi dans un petit objet
c'est ce téléphone
en fait comme ça on peut pas vous
appeler en FaceTime ça comme ça
je sais déjà qu'elle est dans le Perche
avec un mec
c'est honteux ce qu'il fait il dit il
faut faire des fesses de contrôle
regardez le téléphone qu'il a nous avons
ouvert justement
tu détournes la loi de la science ce
téléphone et c'est un aveugle c'est un
aveugle
c'est le mec qui roule à 180°c
moi je vais vous dire moi et même vous
pouvez m'appeler quand vous voulez on
fait stagne je vous répondrai toujours
bah oui mais bon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je répondrai dernier conseil pour se
faire des amis il faut fermer sa gueule
faut apprendre surtout à écouter les
autres oui
ça peut être un conseil pour les timides
par exemple si vous voulez quelquefois
les timide vont parce qu'ils sont ils
sont un petit peu impressionnés ils vont
ne pas écouter ce que va leur dire la
personne et pour préparer leur réponse
mais en réalité ça fausse tout il y a
plein d'études qui ont été montré que
c'est justement sa fausse totalement le
le rapport c'est pareil pour les gens
qui sont un petit peu extravertis qui
parlent trop souvent de même
donc là on est dans le cadre aussi du où
on fausse
et juste finis sur ce truc là c'est de
d'apprendre en fait à se mettre dans la
tête de l'autre et de voir comment ils
voient le monde ça c'est un très à moi
je vais vous dire quand je fais un
rendez-vous avec quelqu'un j'ai vraiment
un vieil adage qui me dit dans ma tête à
chaque fois que j'arrive
ne l'entend pas écoute là oui très bien
entendre ses biens écouter c'est mieux
mais vous arrivez à le faire quand vous
êtes sur votre téléphone en même temps
oui les gars oui oui j'arrive à le faire
c'est fou ça quoi quand j'arrive à le
faire quand je suis vous êtes très
souvent même temps vous vous entendez
tout ce qui se passe dans la pièce et
vous êtes sur votre téléphone en même
temps ça me bloque ah ouais on a
l'impression que on a l'impression que
vous n'écoutez rien de ce qui se passe
vous êtes capable de ressortir la
conversation
vous moi je suis plus trop vous savez
maintenant depuis que ça y est depuis
qu'il y a eu ce foutu papier dans
Libération
je rigole bien sûr
greffer bien sûr pour l'argent